Right now we would like to invite our
guest Avanto professor John seely Brown,
who was conferred and honorary doctor of
information systems degree in
recognition of his outstanding record as
a scientist,
scholar and innovator on the stage to
say a few words,
Professor Brown,
please.
Good afternoon.
Soon as you've already seen,
you can learn a tremendous amount,
but the ability to improvise is a very
good skill.
If you want to be a dean.
Steve
felt for you up here.
I had a brief conversation with Steve
coming over and you heard this morning,
all these magnificent things that I
supposedly have done a while.
I got this wonderful award for it,
but he was surprised when I kind of came
up in a conversation.
I cow did such a hardcore geek as I was
turning into such a softy into such a
person that believes in the power of
social science.
And I said,
Steve,
you know,
it's actually quite simple.
You didn't talk about my first job.
My first job that happened to have been
the youngest licensed bookie in New York
state.
I got that job 18 years old because I
was a geek.
I could compute all kinds of amazing
things in my head with blinding speed,
but within the first day of my job,
I discovered being able to be able to
compute amazingly complex things in my
head,
didn't really matter what really
mattered was being able to read the
people approaching me to make book,
because if you could read them,
you suddenly realize which ones are
going to teach you in which ones
weren't.
And was kind of the first moment that I
began to realize that maybe it was more
important to read context that just be
able to compute the content.
Um,
and that's where I kind of Steve started
down this path,
but that's not why I'm here today.
Today.
We live in,
in some ways a terrifying world,
but also an exciting world.
We've already heard left,
right,
and sideways the amazing kinds of
disruptions that are happening.
But we,
we here in this room have the unusual
property that yes,
we are creating the tools that lead to
radical disruption around the world.
But simultaneously,
we're creating the tools that let us to
build new ways to learn new ways to
work,
new ways to innovate,
new ways to create meeting.
So in some sense we're causing the
disruptions,
but we're also creating the tools in
which to reinvent the industrial world,
the corporate world,
the learning world,
the world of actually making meaning
left,
right and sideways.
So of his call.
This the big shift.
We call it the big shift because perhaps
for the first time in the history of
civilization,
we're moving from a world you might call
an s curve world where you have a moment
of radical punctuation with 50,
60,
70 years or more or less stability in
terms of the infrastructures that
defining how we work,
learn,
interact,
socialize,
etc. Etc.
That has bEen a history of the last 300
years.
Don't worry,
I won't bore you with taking you through
300 years,
but we now live and what we all in this
room would call the exponential world
where basically we no longer have these
long periods of stability with which to
reinvent how we work,
how we learn and so on.
But we're entering as a world in which
in fact we can't even tell our students
what they should know five years from
now because in fact,
we're moving into a world in which the
average half life of a skill is moving
from about 30 years to about five years.
That means that we're going to have to
do most of our learning after we leave
here today,
and we're going to have to do most of
our learning in the workplace itself in
one form or another.
In fact,
those of us that design corporate
architectures,
institutional architectures,
have to step back and realize that for
the last hundred years,
the west became powerful.
The east became powerful because we
could actually build institutions that
understood how to leverage scalable
efficiency.
We knew how to scale things,
but to make things scalable,
they had to become predictable.
Predictability was the coin of the
realm,
and virtually every single corporate
strategy I've ever looked at found new
ways to leverage.
If you wish,
scalable efficiency.
But here's the dirty secret.
Those very things that made her so
successful for the last 50 or 60 years
are the very things that stand in our
way now
because they no longer work because we
don't have predictability.
We can't predict customer needs.
We can't preDict what object to build in
massive quantities,
store up in warehouses and distributed
through superior transportation
infrastructures and so on and so forth.
So some of us have been looking at the
issue of how do we actually move from
basically an underlying strategic basis
of all our institutions of scalable
efficiency to the notion of scalable
learning.
How do we actually think about
reinventing corporations,
public institutions and so on and so
forth,
whose job it is to make sure that those
of us that work in those institutions
learn faster than almost anywhere else.
For example,
why kids today go to google?
Eat by the way,
is not because of money.
Believe it or not,
it's because at google,
in the bay area where I come from,
you will learn faster.
There.
you learn newer technologies there in
virtually any other place in the country
and probably the world.
In fact,
there's a very Interesting book out
called the race against the machine
written by two economists from mit that
are trying to explain why in fact maybe
they're going to be so few jobs are
fewer jobs in the new normal protocol
call,
so to,
so to speak,
um,
because basically most of our jobs as
they claim can now be done by machines.
that probably is somewhat true,
but some of us are reframing the race
against the machine to be the race with
the machine.
How do we actually think about how do we
in the machine work together better than
either one by ourselves,
by themselves,
and in fact,
that causes us to radically we frame
what do we think about in terms of
augmented intelligence,
augmented capabilities to innovate and
so on and so forth.
In fact,
if you play chess,
you may be surprised to know that of
course,
a few years ago,
ibm built this mega machine that
actually ended up building beating the
world champion.
But here's what you might not know.
You take the world's best chess players.
You take the world's best mega machines,
and guess what?
both can be easily beat by a moderately
good chest team playing with a
moderately good machine.
Well these kids have figured out is how
to use the machine to augment what they
do so well.
The pair of those things working
together,
man in machine now beats the hell out of
the world's best chess machine and the
world's best chess players.
So I want to suggest that we go forward.
We have to be very creative in how we
think better about augmenting human
intelligence and how we can work more
effectively with machines.
But I want to suggest equally
challenging because some of you here are
also going to be architecting
organizations of the future.
We ought to be thinking about how do we
reinvent institutional architectures to
actually lead to scalable learning in
the workplace and in our governments and
I think that is a new type of design
challenge and we add to that what we're
now capable of doing with cloud
computing
and now how we can actually rethink
learning on demand as well so that
anytime we get stuck we can pull
information tours,
but that pulling content that's not
pulling context.
That's not pointing dispositions and so
on,
so we gotta kind of be careful to keep
in mind the difference between
character,
difference between dispositions and the
difference between knowledge.
I'm fond of using the term,
the entrepreneurial learner,
not because I'm concerned about how to
train entrepreneurs per se,
but I'm very interested in the
disposition that says,
every moment of the day I personally
have a chance to learn something new and
if you can actually do something,
put yourself out in the edge,
often get stuck and then what you do.
You pull information.
We're moving from an education based on
push to learning on demand pull,
but now I pull the information into a
context,
into a situation that's personally
meaningful to me because it stuck out.
I'm trying to go to use that information
as fast as can be,
a to see if I can get myself unstuck.
So that's how suddenly all of a sudden
learning becomes so real and I can make
it so personal that whatever you do this
way,
you basically never forget.
So I do want to suggest that a couple of
things we should be thinking about as we
leave today.
I think one is to make sure we ourselves
don't get stuck in ruts.
My single biggest advice to most
corporate ceos is what are you doing to
make sure you aren't stuck in a rut?
And if this game is changing every five
years as opposed to every 35 or 40
years,
that means the things that made us
successful yesterday,
maybe exactly the things that blind us
today.
So how do we keep from being stuck in
ruts?
I'm going to suggest the second thing as
we move in increasingly from thinking
about machines is we can take apart like
clocks to we now living in a world where
everything is interconnected.
The smallest moves can now propagate
around the world.
Um,
we may have to shift from thinking about
machines and mechanisms to thinking
about biology as a fundamental metaphor.
How do we think about emerging systems?
How do we begin to understand sometimes
certain moves seem so positive on the
surface,
but ended up having all kinds of
secondary consequences,
which is always a way that many complex
ecological systems actually work,
so I think we're actually going to be
moving if you wish,
as coral poppers,
head on the world of clocks,
mechanical systems that can be
deconstructed and tinkered with here,
buy gear to a world of clouds,
not as a pun,
not as cloud computing,
or they could talk forever about cloud
computing,
but as clowns,
as these things in the sky that are
emergent,
how do we start designing emerging
systems because clouds are complex
adaptive systems and as soon as you
touch it,
something changes.
Those are the challenges we face
tomorrow.
Good luck and helping us all figure out
how to live in the new world.
Thank you.
Thanks.